good morning menu
good morning Millennials you're making
it like British morning I'm thinking it
like mrs. Doubtfire yeah at the end of
the movie when she hosts a children's
show
good morning millennium good morning
Millennials how you doing today
this is the morning toes this was the
morning toes it is a juicy toast some
people are calling it the roast of
tristan thompson because we will get to
it but breaking news is still developing
so much going on in the world today I'm
Claudia joy girls no job I'm Jackie
ashtray Jackie oh problems in the
morning toast oh this is the morning
toast if you didn't know we're gonna
light it on fire today and just watch it
blaze so I hope you're ready are you
ready had your morning toast I hope you
had your morning toast because I think
without further ado we have to get into
the past five stories that you need to
know before you wake about wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
charms because Tristan third trimester
trimester Thompson that's what they're
calling him yeah because he left his
other girlfriend when she was pregnant
with her third child my god that's
terrible actually oh my god twice I
didn't know that she was pregnant yeah
and he left her for Chloe during her
third trimester so truly right now you
get him it's how you lose him so we are
obviously breaking down the Tristan
Thompson scandal that occurred I think
was at the Gramercy Park Hotel from the
pictures that I was like trying to save
me I thought it was at the dream no I
don't think so
I don't mean I don't know but I was just
trying to get her to the Four Seasons
yeah the Four Seasons is confirmed the
club where he was at is unconfirmed so
what the shade room the shade room on
and ceramic really broke this story and
I just love with like other successful
Instagram brands like you know get good
stuff I'm like happy for that me right I
agree very especially how for Instagram
brands who don't support other Instagram
brands there was this Instagram post if
you haven't seen it go check it out on
the Shay broom pictures of Tristan
Thompson over the weekend he was in New
York because they were playing the
Knicks he was at a club making out with
girls and then this video like security
footage of Tristan at a restaurant in
October making out with two girls and
like motorboating them came out
that's an old video the pictures are
recent then there was an apparent
Instagram like sex tape that I watched
and I don't think it was real no it's
definitely not really
like it could be anyone's Johnson right
also there's something I would like to
it doesn't have to be his Thompson I'm
nice okay but I just want to say I'm
speaking of sex tape yesterday we were
talking about Drake Bell someone sent me
the the video and they whoever edited it
like made a collage of like all the
pictures all the videos and set it to
the theme song of Dragan dodge and it
was horrified like it was horrible that
it was traumatizing I'm sure that's like
Dan Schneider there's wet dream by the
way I was doing something the same thing
the whole time and all those chip we
were saying about icarly yesterday like
I can't sit he has ruined everything you
can separate that icarly stand in the
Dan Schneider yeah just like the mark
sailing from the Glee exactly except
I've done a really good job of
separating it because I just [ __ ]
love Glee and I refused to let it be
ruined
I didn't like love iCarly as a kid you
know I know that you did know I didn't I
was like no I really like I wasn't into
it
she lied I wasn't no we need to talk
about Tristan Thompson because there's
so much to unpack here because first of
all so this past weekend he was caught
smooching another woman taking her back
to the hotel and that prompted TMZ to
release video from something that
happened six months ago at a hookah
lounge of him motorboating yeah it
really is like the Jersey Shore no like
he had his head between two briefs on
Twitter did something so funny and like
we wrote the letter the Jersey Shore
cast wrote Ron and Sam and it was like
Sam two nights ago when you were out in
bed tryst and they wrote it with like
Chloe two trimesters ago when you were
pregnant Tristan was that a car a bar
and put his head between a cocktail
waitresses breasts it's so funny I mean
it's not funny cuz obviously it's sad
for Khloe but like I mean as someone
who's like heavily invested in like
celebrity like pop culture gossip and
weeds a lot of brides like I was not
surprised with this and also just like
knowing that everyone cheats like
nothing surprises me yeah I don't think
either I don't think Khloe surprised
either I just think it's just bad timing
and she's embarrassed yeah she's
embarrassed odd oh she's literally
embarrassed and pregnant which is what
embarrass Auto means really do you watch
like any stand-up comedy sometimes
because I know you take sketch comedy
really seriously why because they're
this community called Sebastian
Maniscalco yeah you've talked
and like like tagline his comedic
tagline is aren't you embarrassed and
he's when people do bigger things it's
like aren't you embarrassed
so like Tristan aren't too about he
doesn't seem to be too embarrassed and
like he did it so publicly while Chloe
is in Cleveland like getting ready to
pop so sad I just feel sad for her
because it's like she obviously can't
stay with him she can't stay in
Cleveland but I feel like she really
likes Cleveland and like wants to stay
there regardless yeah and also like it
just sucks because like when something
like this happens really like you have
got like the privilege of like hiding in
your house like Tristan has to play
these games like every night so if we
get to see him it like he has to do
interviews like about like you get fined
if you don't go to the press conferences
so like I just think it like sucks for
him yeah as it should suffer yeah
because I we can stay in the house in
Cleveland where she's safe I just think
it's like in his house actually it's not
so crazy cuz like I know that everyone
cheats but like it's just crazy that
there's proof do you know what I mean
and it's crazy the timing like I think
she could go into labor if she's not if
she had already it's also like I think
when you're stressed
it could cause like contractions oh
she's already them yeah last night
people are saying that Christiana
released the video I don't know she the
devil works hard but Kris Jenner works
harder and I agree but like why would
she intentionally embarrass her daughter
she she wouldn't people think honestly
like Kris Jenner is everything because I
thank you for like too much credit I
totally agree there's no way that she
did that it makes no sense I wouldn't
put it past blac Chyna but how would she
have gotten that video oh my god wait so
I read a blind I know the show we don't
want the show to become like blind
conspiracy it's like this is in the
morning line you know and this is like
we're reputable news show and not all
blinds were true and there are some that
like I've read that I still don't
believe and I don't meet children and we
have the same one that we don't believe
is it about she went no that's what I
refuse to believe Nick Jonas what the
blind says about hmm was that because of
this video that surface of blac Chyna
like she's losing her child support
payments that she really can't live
without them and so she's all this dirt
on the Kardashians that she's starting
to release in order to blackmail them
into giving her child support it's like
maybe this is it but like I don't know
how she would have gotten access to the
security footage of like a hookah bar no
but she might have gotten
access to picture someone just wrote in
the comments which I haven't seen
anywhere else that um the girl is
friends with blac Chyna so maybe like
this girl like China had this girl have
her friends take pictures of her in the
club the double works are DeGeneres
owner who obviously buried this story
six months one reason or another I'm
sure the Kardashians gave them a
different story and live with it meaning
that they knew this whole time then TMZ
was like well we need the exclusive yes
the media is so cool ah this is that
yeah that's how are they wheeling and
dealing all over Miami I feel like I
really imagine this is how Harvey what
set us everyone's it with Harvey Levin
love it it's at a desk will and deal it
making moves making deals go you got
this I got the exclusive you want it ten
minutes okay see you there it's tired
yeah Harvey Levin plays such a strong
arm does it taste so skinny between
hating and loving Harvey Levin um you
know what I like him made you like some
people graduated lies about me and like
on on TMZ TV but they were funny like
like he said that Donald Trump tweeted
about me like [ __ ] I made that up it
was a lie like like where where is the
research like does nobody have to like
do like that anything anymore no but it
was a fake tweet you didn't lied you
didn't say that he treated you when he
didn't you made a fake tweet which is
like a form of comedy these days like
and they just don't check anything
you're not a chance let's no split it's
like I'm sure after the fact they found
out that that was not the case and okay
god forbid they issue a rebuttal so yeah
no of course not yeah moving on Tristan
Thompson that's why it's so crazy late
that's why I have such a different
outlook I'm like what's reported now
because as I said yesterday like where
there's smoke there's probably not a
fire and everyone has an angle yeah so
like this video being released of
Tristan like what's the real story yeah
like how many other girls like why now
why'd this girl why now because
obviously he seems like a perpetual
cheater this is definitely not the first
time he's done anything like this I just
feel bad for Chloe she can't catch a
break man lies I mean yeah my first
sneeze on the truss hold on
if you think I'm a mod to Mike's make
sounds when these needs interesting
interesting question I couldn't you just
really broken that's one of those memes
like hits blood do mine sake sounds when
they cease I feel like they do we have
to let get the call wait if I'm I'm
farts does it count for the Mun it's
fine for mine yeah okay sorry what were
you talking about
Tristan and Chloe she like I feel bad
for her she can to get us good men but
like that's just what happens when you
might be bored associate athletes I feel
like I just watched so much wags and
it's just it's not real it's not real
it's so crazy and like at the fact that
Jesse James Decker and what's-his-face
have like continued a marriage it's just
it's shocking I just feel like there has
to be a level of what's accept like
obviously cheating goes on so there has
to be a level of like agreement and
acceptability and I think the agreement
was probably don't [ __ ] do it in
public and embarrass me in public doe
contracta Sen embarrass me when I'm
embarrassed Otto that's good
let's okay so there's a proclamation
when you would date a and it says that
there's nuances We the People in order
to form a more perfect union of two
people we shall not achieve in public we
shall not contract STDs
we must always use a condom in our own
condom so you kill is a whole no one I'm
related to you know like no one that I
know yeah I think that's their and maybe
they don't fall in love I mean no one
don't fall in love at the Jersey Shore
okay back to yeah that goes without
saying
find the way I don't know like this is
just being made like a huge spectacle
like everyone's freaking out like I
wasn't like don't I'm things happen and
I'm shocked like when I saw him at China
in forenoon like I was like you know but
when this happened that was like home
sad I know I wasn't surprised just
because it I've come to expect it and I
don't know it's obviously a big deal
know for sure but it didn't rock my
world like it's rockin so many people's
no yeah my world is pretty stable right
now yeah for the most part yeah I don't
know I just feel so sorry I feel sorry
for her I hope she just like but she had
it going on like I think if she already
knew about this like she
her career and now she has she's gonna
have a beautiful child and I think
that's what she really really want and
like at some point like when you win
your luck pregnant and like you're about
to have your first kid like nothing else
matters so like right it's fine it's
fine and at least she's having a child
with a man so say they don't stay
together like at least he's like
financially stable as near as we know so
she and like he's not gonna be calling
on her for like child support and also
like at least she's rich and famous and
much she gets to fly private everywhere
she's fine and like he has so many kids
yeah
like running around the world that maybe
she'll get like full custody of this one
and believers and he won't have to deal
with him let this be a lesson how do you
get them is how do you lose them no have
you been cheated on someone no it would
require like being in a relationship
yeah cry or two no me neither
we're some nice but also how you got him
is how you lose him so like yes she
could have lost him be a cheating but it
the fact that it was like the same point
in the pregnancy like that's just that's
the devil's work well so the way that it
works is that not the way that it works
both times this is what Ben was telling
me is that when she was in the trimester
third trimester and now Chloe's in the
third trimester it was also like right
before the NBA finals or something so
maybe he doesn't like to get his mojo
I don't know cuz he won a bunny cheated
on the first wife fiancee whatever well
well I feel like that's just the
Kardashian blessing some call it a curse
I think it's a it's a blessing it's how
you handle it that makes it a curse hmm
um but it's so crazy cuz the footage
from the hookah bar was the night before
they played like the Warriors I don't
know what city that's in and it's like
they're allowed out before a big game I
was thinking the same thing because I
know anything it was like drink they're
not and they'd like stay in the same
hotel room is like other players I don't
know I don't know but then I feel like
it's like there's so many players there
are so many games like can't you have a
row of you you know and like they're
really gonna keep these grown men in
line ladies at summer camp right but it
kind of is no I don't know it's very
confusing
well this is a developing story the
toast will obviously keep you informed
with what's going on but right now we
just wish our best to Chloe
we hope this isn't stressing around too
much and then she has a wonderful Labor
experience
there's so much like fake news going on
on out there about this so many fake
accounts like that sex tape that I don't
even think is real and it's like but I
watch it even the media doesn't even
know what's real and what's fake because
they're just like citing whatever the
[ __ ] they can get their hands on cuz
everyone just wants me first so I just
say like take the time to really um fact
check the whole thing you're like we'll
just let the toast do it for you or let
the toys do it for you exactly okay that
story actually shakes me to the core and
I'm just gonna sum it up in one word she
by Sheree has been fired from your
highnesses of Atlanta I feel like this
is such an injustice but what I'm
learning is that like my perspective on
housewives is very different from that
of the world if I watched if I learned
anything from watching watch for happens
live last night this is the thing she by
Sheree was was robbed
all the ladies hate her because she's
friends with Kim why is that there she's
The Bone Collector I don't know but here
is why the source tells Us Weekly that
Ray was fired after the filming of
season 10 reunion and his quote very
upset the source adds that her
relationship with her boyfriend Tyrone
Gilliam's who is currently serving 10
years in prison for stealing five
million dollars in wire fraud schemes
may have played a role in the network's
decision not to bring her back
Bravo can't film inside or even outside
the jail this is causing a problem with
her storyline and so unless she intends
to really bring back she by Sheree for
September spring/summer yeah then
weathers then what is n lifestyle of
course then what is it going to be it
out yes she needed a job as Susan she by
Gucci no he goes what's going on was she
best raise your doggers like she by
Gucci
I think his her dress was Gucci I don't
know I know she was making little to no
sense on the first installment of
possibly a ladder Union I feel bad
because like obviously she's like guilty
by association everyone hates Kim so
she's getting fired but she didn't do a
good job of like being a housewife so
like honestly like it makes sense but I
just like her and you got to play the
game like this is your job these aren't
your real friendships so like if that
requires you to like go out to lunch and
like have a crisp white wine with
someone just do it you know none of the
things we have to do and like you're
getting paid to do that like go fit
treat these people like your co-workers
like yeah nobody likes their co-workers
yeah I mean work with that we're
coworkers do you like me yes what am I
like as a co-worker
you know you're definitely you're like
the office like I don't know gossip I am
I don't know meet me by the water cooler
yeah you're definitely if you really
like worked in the corporate setting
like you definitely be hanging out by
the water floor no just definitely like
just go to the bathroom and sit on the
toilet I'll get it
yeah that's a thing that people do or
cry
cry and then that cry so hard I have to
fall asleep those are the best naps like
you just cry so hard you're like
exhausted it's just so crazy but you're
like working on a desk and you look
forward to the smallest things like the
best like having to pee so you drink
more yeah but then it's like that's why
this show is really so incredible yeah
because literally what 30 minutes have
gone by and you haven't done anything I
work you're welcome no wait here's the
thing
we started the show at 10:30 so say you
watch five we go from 10:30 to 11:30 you
an hour is gone then you're on the the
toast hi and then it's noon and then you
have lunch no this is how your day goes
you get to work around the clock from
9:00 to 10:00 you like say how to sound
you make good coffee get a coffee you
poop that's your babe you know you check
your facebook check email checking gchat
then it's 10:30 you put in headphones
you pretend like you're like doing
important production stuff and from
10:30 to 11:30 you were served the most
premium content from 11:30 12:00 o'clock
you meet Sally back by the water cooler
do you brief the toast be like oh my god
Khloe looks amazing her how there was
some fake Jacki share it loved it so
much is she wearing culottes again haha
Sally
it's well I'm gonna look at that time
for lunch 12 to 4 o'clock is lunch
sounds like an amazing day to me and we
know Monday through Friday so you never
and then you have to like worry on the
weekends like oh no there's a test like
I want to go D drink but I don't want to
sleep in no yes like to worry we're not
working overtime so you don't have to
it's just it's really mutually
beneficial actually I'm not sure how
benefits us yet but oh yeah okay I make
you know money and nobody watches the
show so how's that kinds of people
record highs actually the record highs
for Monday yeah and now you know cuz
everyone was just like thirsting to see
what we were gonna do with this we're
gonna do the usual and we're gonna tell
you the news as we don't be so surprised
as we were telling you yesterday we are
on a mission to beat felonious Florida
in the App Store
I mean podcast app store we're still
number two behind it it's so annoying
there must be like a paywall like
there's something that
we are not getting because they only
have two episodes it's not even like
they're releasing new episodes yeah I
don't know how does it get in front of
felonious or I'm really happy at number
two I can't explain it because it's like
if we're at number one then it's like
the only place we can go is down that's
true I know more - like we can still go
up and we can also go like an optimist I
just like being above like the New York
Times at NPR it's like it's hell there
it's hilarious like look at this like we
are a joke I've been wearing the same
jeans five days in a row and I'm above
NPR you know it's litoris it's hilarious
that's why you for number one it's like
it's too funny you know it's almost like
not funny I don't how about you funny it
is you know it's like what is the world
to come to like the morning toast the
audio yeah so crazy and it's like that's
number you know that's at your testament
to the world that we're living in like
people are tired of faking it was like
we are real news yeah
oh man that's why we can be number one
no okay I'm you know I take it back now
it's like getting the first impression
for a sec you don't want the first
impression we don't want to be a little
bit rainy no and you do not want to be
Chelsea the mom Oh totally you just
wanna like middle line command and no no
you wanna be a minute oh my god you want
to be a minister like you're well known
pretty everyone likes you be like you're
not like an obvious winner here no name
it's like it's I always come here it's
like dodgeball it's like you don't want
to be and this isn't go same for Real
Housewives you don't want to be the one
at the front throwing all the balls yeah
you're gonna get people out but you're
gonna get out faster if you stay in the
back you play it safe for a while all of
a sudden you're in the final two do you
think anyone has so all of a sudden you
have the most Instagram powers from
people on the show do you think you've
so bigger as' anyone in the history of
the we're all just so vigorously I'm
like analyze the podcast top charts
probably I'm sure there's like a podcast
about podcasts yeah should we start one
I don't know like podcasts are just it's
so the power podcast world is so crazy
because okay a crazy medium like the
amount of people that listen to podcast
is crazy
personally before we ever started a
podcast I didn't listen to podcast
except one so I would listen to Stassi
vision when I worked at this job but now
everyone has a podcast so it's like kind
of a joke no it's but it's not still
it's not a joke it's frustrating
honestly
like it's a digital radio like it's like
everyone was a podcast couldn't get a
radio show and it's turning out to be
more beneficial cuz it's more lucrative
and like there's just so many people
wanting to listen to podcasts so when
people like Dax Shepard who's a I'm Anna
Faris who are traditional celebrities
and could get a radio show
go on podcast it denying is how [ __ ] off
like Dax Shepard is always beating us in
the comedy thing cuz like he's a real
celebrity and yes Jimmy keep his guest
Lauren Graham was his newest guest
Jimmy Kimmel Kristen Bell it's a good
doing we can't compete with that
[ __ ] off stay in your lane yeah like you
go back to traditional media the digital
go to a movie go do a refrigerator
commercial when do you go on Ellen wait
me I was a guest stop that's crazy
we need to talk about Ellen because
Mason Ramsey I keep calling him
mason-dixon but that's the line I keep
calling him Randy Moses are you probably
a name oh okay mason-dixon but Mason
Ramsey was on Ellen yesterday Mason
Nancy is the Walmart yodeling boy who I
am in love with he went on Ellen and it
made me feel a lot of things first of
all I mean the only time I see him it
gives me a Pitt because like he is too
pure for this world and him on Ellen
gave me an enormous pit because he's too
pure for Hollywood and I'm just like so
worried like even like Noah Ritter who
was so pure like where is he now he's
probably like I'm not even gonna say
anything don't cuz he's fine I felt like
I felt him really he posts once a year
and what are see doing the other 360
still Ellen keeps all those kids in her
ellentube Network and they like make
money in like our fine
she's like the Jake Paul yeah exactly
but I don't know the this segment with
the kid like made me feel weird it made
me feel weird and it's like she a be
obviously a kid gets famous and you're
like it can't wait for them to go on
Ellen yeah so Ellen does her duty and
brings mom but like she was not
interested in him yeah she sort of
medium and he was saying the cutest
[ __ ] thing why do you perform at
Walmart it's the only thing in our town
like stop stop wait wait she was like
what are you gonna do with all your fame
I'm gonna go to college and like I just
wasn't appreciated she wasn't
appreciating just me the pureness that
he was exude abut its I'm gonna go to
college I'm gonna move to Florida and I
want to go to the Opera I'm gonna move
up in a mobile trailer
makes no sense no absolutely perfect
sense everyone knows I think see all the
money he's gonna make is like only gonna
be able to afford college nobody's
looking for him like college is like I'm
Ginny grandparents didn't go to college
raising him are like you know just
saving up for college cut like all he
hears is like all this money it takes to
go to college
no he's literally like everything that's
right in this world like he's so
untouched by anything like able like he
just grew up in the most like pure home
like with so much love and I just had
like Ellen was being kind of mean to him
and like making him feel stupid and he
had never been on a plane before and he
wasn't even fazed by the plane he was
amazed by the limousine drivers name
being the same as his grandpa and it
just makes me sad that they brought him
to Hollywood because Hollywood is
disgusting cesspool the center of all
that is wrong and evil with this world
and like now Mason Ramsey is touched by
it totally but like he definitely the
best time really and when he went over
$15,000 stop why did you say that Jackie
what's wrong with you I'm just saying
like children in Hollywood are not
protected oh for sure but like that was
very dark and something I would say I
feel darkly about it no me too but like
are you okay you know I really stopped
oh my god that was crazy I can't we just
said that why I don't know do you think
you went over to buy gum no like on its
tour as he probably did like a studio
tour whatever everyone knows that Ellen
is evil and like I just don't think she
should have been the first one to like
you know who really yeah you know who
should have interviewed us know like
seriously
Al Roker like you seems like such a nice
guy yeah the weather guy like Lee Harvey
yes oh and he does that show little big
chops
yeah oh my god already on I watched
comedians in cars getting oh my god so
funny so funny he's just like it's such
a man about town I love Kevin Hart's
episode I know you I did like I loved it
I know I've watched it before because
all the stories he was telling I was
like I already knew that we obviously
like just find out about comedian cars
gonna call me and we've been like we're
watching the whole series it's really
funny but can I tell you who does not do
it for me Jimmy Fallon Jerry Seinfeld
what like I just don't I never watch
Seinfeld and like I mean I only watch
curb so I just feel like Larry David
comes up with all of his jokes for him
so like I just I know he's like the
funniest man and then I watched Larry
David episode
then I was like to Zack who loves Sam
how about it's like who do you think is
funnier who do you think is funnier um
Jerry Seinfeld and let me tell you why
because Jerry Seinfeld like his stand-up
is like PG at most pg-13 and like Larry
David is like oh he's talking about like
Octopussy sorry and I just think it's
like so much more admirable for someone
to be like a clean comic like I tried to
be and it's not easy angry and I don't
know like Larry David's really funny
curb is really funny but like sometimes
it takes it looking way too far but like
sometimes seem that hits the nail on the
head like when he did that episode about
Palestinian chicken like that was funny
yeah I like that's addressing a conflict
in a funny way right um I do you think
Jerry Seinfeld is like just like it's a
cooler it's like dad jokes it's funny I
guess I've never actually watched his
stand-up well if you watch Seinfeld they
put segments of his stand-up like in
between the commercials what is he what
is his occupation in Seinfeld a comedian
huh yeah the show is fun like sometimes
it's I doesn't do it for me Ben loves it
this has been much as I thought is it
like Ben doesn't stop laughing and
sometimes it's really funny like because
the way it's the same Larry David thing
like the beginning of the episode always
comes back to the end of episode and
it's like stuff that happens because
sometimes things happen I'm like this is
like a Larry thing let me try to explain
what episode that I just watched you
like it's so stupid but like it did you
ever watch the curb episode with the
girl from 22 Jump Street you know that
girl from rough night I told you to I
did it with the belly show no I didn't
but I will oh my god Katya whatever it's
good it's a very specific brand of
comedy like I feel like our animatics
would like it you know because she takes
sketch comedy very seriously yeah and a
lot of other things very seriously she's
like kind of a big meows okay do you
want to move on to the next story yeah
okay Mariah Carey reveals her secret
battle with bipolar disorder um in the
new issue of people the singer opens up
about living with bipolar two disorder
and why she kept it a secret from the
public for nearly two decades Kerry was
first diagnosed in 2001 after she was
hospitalized for a mental and physical
breakdown
back then quote I didn't want to believe
it four years after her hospitalization
carried recalls I was so terrified of
losing everything I convinced myself the
only way to deal with this was to not
deal with this after quote the hardest
couple of years Kerry recently sought
treatment until recently I lived in
denial and
isolation and constant fear someone
would expose me it was too heavy a
burden to carry and I simply couldn't do
that anymore
I sought and received treatment I put
positive people around me and I got back
to doing what I love writing songs and
making music she says Kari says she's
now in therapy and taking medication to
manage her bipolar two disorder which is
characterized by extended periods of
depression hypomania and mood swings
quote I'm actually taking medication
that seems to be pretty good it's not
making me feel too tired or sluggish or
anything like that she says finding the
proper balance is what's the most
important this is so crazy and kind of
like amazing it's giving me like Gemma
Lovato bad ii love when celebrities talk
about mental health because like there's
a lot of shame around it but like with
Mariah Carey can come out and be like
skinny and pretty and like say that I
have pebble disorder like it's not a
deal
yeah very brave but I also understand
like why taking her so long
you gotta move out of like became famous
in like this new she went through it all
publicly and it's like in this new age
where so much of like all of that is
accepted and like embraced whereas like
I think feel like in 2001 like tabloids
were still like calling people out right
fat or like yeah that's crazy or like
just you know you couldn't you could say
a lot more yeah and so I understand why
like she felt that way then but I'm so
glad I'm so happy for her cause really -
there's so much like pleasured about
like her and what she does and heard
even is she so like look like behind
like she's very private yeah and I think
this is this is amazing and she looks
amazing on the cover right yeah I kind
of feel like it's a weird that that's it
that is oh I don't actually know if this
works but if you could see it let's see
I think it's a little weird that it's in
people do you know what I mean
well I mixed rattles the line between
being a trash tabloid they could buy in
the airport but they also being a
reputable news source and like I feel
like their version of being a reputable
news source is like almost like a parody
on reputable news sources you know it's
like we're gonna do a sit-down exclusive
and with merciful heart attack you know
it's like Ari and Lauren like you've
never seen them before and it's like
yeah you've never seen them that way
before because they're retouched beyond
recognition maybe that's why I like I
find it hard to take People magazine
seriously cuz like the rain just like I
feel like because they have that 52
issues a year like 30 of them are
Bachelor related so look how serious of
a publication can be there's also like
the true crime a there's always or like
a war hero
home and like his wife had cheated on
him like real people's story it's just
like a weird magazine like every and
just so much weight loss yes
The Biggest Loser usually have lost
weight welcome to People magazine how
can we help you it's just like the
trajectory of like their content is
bizarre then you turn the page and you
truly never know what you're gonna get
great so maybe that's why people like it
so much
yeah it's like you don't know it's like
I just I'm wondering the impetus behind
choosing People magazine because I carry
on the cover literally anyone would have
her that's true she could have done
vogue like a mile clooney yeah she's on
the cover of Vogue no yes it's beautiful
beautiful except they put her in a top
that's like very 90s like wait I have to
google it it did both America I believe
so no let me check I always check that
first cuz like it cuz look it's an honor
to be on vogue but like obviously
there's ya know there's just a
difference also but uh French Vogue is
actually like and it's British Vogue oh
yeah cuz they're always trying to like
replace Anna Wintour or maybe I'm just
confusing Devil Wears Prada with real
life now they're always trying to please
her and a written tour with the editors
news posts oh my ugh give it to me it's
okay okay in my shot on my way here I
should have showed you where we were in
the car together we carpool now yeah we
you and make Somoza she's you carpool
karaoke Claud give it to me I'm gonna
show you I can't I want to like find it
myself which over it's okay it's a slow
it's a slider watch her they deleted it
it's like a lawyers on the cover like
that's why I'm all Clooney is like an
epic know what an anomaly animala me
okay okay so that was the photo that was
the photo and this is the cover okay
she's amazing here that top is terrible
it's like it's another friends yeah I
think Rachel didn't wear that of friends
I don't know maybe she was inspired by
Ben's birthday party I don't know I just
think it's like there are some people
who like puzzle me and I'm all is one of
them she's in it you didn't hear me
before she's in Amala me I did hear you
but I love is eat Chinese show you how
like she's a lawyer and she's on the
cover of Vogue she's so many things
she's a socialite she has celebrity
she's a lawyer
she's a humanitarian she's humanitarian
just like a model like she she's an
activist what is she and she's like
gonna be the first lady of something
totally I think
the two of them are gonna be yeah I
could church he's so weird
tensions are uncle if he had sex with
Carol rods well stop
I love I can't believe he used to date
it's easy keyboard
no I can't believe Stacy Keibler used to
be in WWE that's what's so crazy
wait that's why it's weird why do you
think it's weird just because like it's
cc keyboard just feel like I don't know
she gives me such like if she gives
those bags because she was in WWE
she gives me such like deal about D F G
she was in W Jimmy and there's like
clips of hide a body on the computer
Jackie there's body slimming clips of
her like online you have to watch let's
put them on our Instagram or Instagram
so lately we finally found that video we
were talking about yesterday of like the
sometimes I ride yet everywhere in u.s.
Americans as American in like everywhere
such as South Africa and the Iraq and
they don't have like education such as
maps it's the best video we throw nerd
sir a Mustang do you remember when when
you watch it like you didn't remember
yes no but I had seen it before she was
still pretty that girl yeah so she like
literally toured the country but the
actual winner is could you imagine how
infuriating that would be such as
everywhere like such as South Africa I
was up to no apparently she got married
looks like not anymore
she's gonna look like Emily Maynard oh
yeah I adore whom I adore um okay I want
to skip to the fifth story just because
Immokalee me is a fantastic segue
because Brad Pitt is absolutely smitten
with MIT professor Neri Oxman it's so
crazy so like four months we've been
speculating on the show who bribed me
Margot Robbie Jennifer Lawrence and you
know we thought about I didn't know how
dairy Oxman just slipped my mind
okay where does she meet an MIT
professor I'll tell you the secret's out
Brad Pitt has a new woman in who does
MIT professor Neri Oxman
Brad's absolutely smitten by her a pitch
source reveals exclusively in the new
issue of Us Weekly their chemistry is
off the charts since last fall
Hollywood's most eligible bachelor has
been quietly date
the award-winning architectural designer
after admiring a line of her 3d printed
chaise lounges that's a good joke was
written on April 1st at MIT where she
teaches Media Arts and Sciences at the
Massachusetts schools Media Lab Oxman is
the first person to whom Pitt has been
linked since its headline-making slit
from Angelina Jolie in September 2016
this story gives me a Brad Pitt lounge
chairs like yeah
but by the way associated works at MIT
but she's like a media and arts teacher
that's like the lowest like I was she's
an architect and she prints on her 3d
printer chaise lounges I need to print a
job I was I need to print a chaise
lounge for my oppose it so this is a
fancy way of saying she's a furniture
designer
they got romantically involved almost
right away he's been going to great
lengths to make sure he's not spotted by
prying eyes um she's Israeli oh my god I
made so much fun of her
I am oh I am pierced of all like okay
this is the thing when your this is a
picture when you're married to the most
beautiful woman in the world like it's
you can only go down from that's like so
I like being the number one podcast so I
just I don't know this is so weird I
expected more from Brad Pitt like like
we said yesterday I love when
celebrities use their dating life as I
got a catapult for more stardom like and
I just think for his career and like for
his reputation it would've been like so
glamorous of him to date like Margot
Robbie Jennifer Laurent there's no way
he could become a bigger star and the
only thing that could happen is he could
get more like paparazzi and be in the
tabloids more which he does not want so
I think dating a private citizen is good
for him and it's very George Clooney of
him like an educated woman
age-appropriate who just like it's not
just arm candy no I'm sorry it's weird I
don't like it really I like it I just
like that picture I just heard I just
can't believe we didn't predict it no
yeah I mean cuz I was thinking like
Margot Robbie maybe you found my Robbie
made Jennifer Lawrence she's single and
then if not Jennifer Lawrence Oh Martin
XM whatever heinous Neri Oxman bar Nexon
Neri Oxman yeah and what do you think
brad calls are like oxy Mary
yeah and from there there whatever I'm
clear I'm happy I just want happiness
for him truly because I justice for Brad
Pitt he should hang out with David
Foster
yes women who are getting sympathy and
they might not deserve no he literally
is probably just so excited to be like
traveling again like he was locked up in
his house with like organic food and
like no deodorant children like we're
gonna do puberty like we're different
People magazine that house like I don't
even want to know what goes on inside
that house yeah between like all the
kids who like Angelina doesn't let them
like shower or we use deodorant with
chemicals in it so they all definitely
like stink and they like they cook like
hemp and a chia seeds and like they
don't go to school they're like our
homeschool so they like never leave the
house I just I don't know that house
gives me that Corner's that that house
should to have a show on TLC for sure
that's never gonna happen but I'm happy
for him in Navy one of them I'd love to
see a photo of them together I don't
know it just was giving me ammo
I just get a you know we are um how
we're gonna be reporting which is on the
cover of Vogue but it's cool no she's on
the cover of Architectural Digest so I'm
sure she already has been yeah it's cool
he's like an educated woman like what a
change of pace for society I agree I
agree
even though Angelina Jolie is like it
said you oh yes she is educated she's
just wild okay
last story amanda Bynes is furious with
Twitter and Instagram for not taking
down fake accounts that are claiming
that she's broke and asking people if I
was a victim or this because I was like
reading the apparently like there's just
Twitter account that everyone thought
was like her underground Twitter account
there's a 20 parish in LA yeah and I was
following it no Michael me actually I
was gonna bend mo her she was like
asking people for money
were you really yeah she needs her meds
she she's only $63 short of being able
to purchase her necessary medications
this account is saying and amanda has
reported these accounts and Twitter and
Instagram have said they're parody
accounts so they don't violate or not
they're not dirty accounts oh my godula
speaking up did you watch the Zuckerberg
thing you know but you told me about it
where would I watch it it was sweeter or
they'd be streaming on it look it was
trying everywhere okay but it was it was
wild first of all like you act c-span
yeah you could just hear first of all he
looked tired and like sad and like dark
and I I was feeling many what exactly is
he there for for the user data
and Cambridge yeah basically like they
were investigating it's a good publicly
traded company that like gave away
people's information so like it's like a
big scandal and they were supposed to be
focusing on that even though like not
one person asked any questions about the
data except one they were like of all
the Senators who are 60 and above one of
them was like 45 and he was like so in
tune with what was going on I don't know
his name he was hot as hell and he was
actually asking like informed questions
about the data he was like you say that
like we own our data but like you're
making money off of it so don't you
really own the data it was like actually
interesting everyone else was being
grandfather central but Ted Cruz FD who
was competitor is like can I do the same
thing on Twitter that I can do on
Facebook it was literally like helping
out your grandfather it was so
infuriating because I feel like these
days the only people who are on Facebook
are old people that's true but they
don't understand like the nuances look
unlike the content strategy at Facebook
if he was trying to explain him it was
so painful the amount of people that
were they were crazy every time
literally Mark Zuckerberg like picks his
nose the cameras you could hear like
Justin with no flash it was crazy that
is and the pictures of him that have
come out he literally looks like he
wants to die that's crazy I should watch
that it's actually it's a big historical
moment that like it's a big deal and
it's just like I was watching it I was
watching blue blood under like
investigation well what's this this is I
can summon him you can't just get on
once you show up at your course is some
sort of investigation that's gonna
result in something but literally
yesterday we should because I guess
today I'll be net word it sounds like it
affects us his net worth grew by two
billion dollars yesterday why I don't
know but like I really think that like
an adult I was watching Blue Bloods and
then on my phone I saw that I was
streaming like a muted blue bloods and
like watch it for 30 minutes and I'm
like wow I'm an adult
it's like the first time like the news
ever like meant anything to me you know
it happens a couple times like yeah also
with like the only minutes in here yeah
but it's just sometimes interesting
moments in history and I'm sure we'll
look back on yes I remember yes Moira
it's like Harry and Megan except I'll
remember every minute so amanda bynes is
taking major umbrage with these
publications and honestly she deserves
to justice her Amanda Bynes I cannot
trust it enough like my opinions on her
have changed tremendously since the
beverage let's come to light
even though it hasn't come to light yet
still in the dark but I I shined a
flashlight on but no she's she's
starting to put the dimmer on you know
it's getting a little bit brighter every
day I just can't wait till it's it's
right
so what was on last night Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills which was
honestly a struggle to get through one
because not much happened and two
because I had to watch live on my iPad
because they still don't have cable well
I found out today that that's a choice
that you've made I felt like the cable
company I was taking late to come it's
two things
it's the cable we haven't called the
cable company yet because we're writing
another TV so we have to wait till we
have our TVs and two we might go with
YouTube TV but like we haven't sampled
it yet so I don't know I think that
would be a mistake but let's talk about
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
ever since my eye opening moment
yesterday that like everyone loves Teddy
I'm having the hardest time watching it
because then I watch watch watch Robbins
live and the poll question was like does
everyone the audience think that Teddy I
mean Erica was way too hard on teddy and
overwhelmingly people were like yes oh
my god
literally Erica didn't do anything the
season she said one thing about being
accused of being a liar and now she's a
villain it's like I hate I hate everyone
what's wrong with I know we're right I
know I know we're right and I just want
to say the winner of this week's episode
was Lisa Rinna or two comments that she
made well actually I wrote some things
down I wrote some what he said oh my god
we're having so much fun on this boat I
wonder if it's because Lisa Vanderpump
is in here yeah the way she's coming
from Lisa Vanderpump especially how she
did on watch repens live is everything
I [ __ ] hate Lisa and what happened
between her and Lisa Vanderpump my
mantra diamonds I've won Lisa Vanderpump
threw in one of her snide Brunei's were
from the side and humored that she
should go back to diapers and dusters
and Rinna knows those sailors and
dusters have made me more money than any
of your restaurants Oh
[Applause]
financial situation I know everyone
thinks that like she's so wealthy and
I'm sure she does fine but I feel like
it's a bit of a facade yes and like it's
just I don't I don't I don't know I
don't want to say anything I just feel
like I wouldn't be surprised if one day
there's like a you know she's running
like a Ponzi restaurant skiers know
because even like butts hissar is
definitely very popular I've been a
bunch of times it's boppin Villa Blancas
is not pump is so like even at your most
two successful restaurants which she has
partners in so she doesn't own full
amounts of them and she has investors
like she doesn't own she doesn't get all
the revenue like do you live that lavish
of a lifestyle with the Rolls Royce when
you have two successful restaurants but
she's had like I think thirty in her day
Oh
and what does Ken do do they do it
together yeah it's confusing you're
right and like they just spend so much
money and then sometimes I look at what
she's wearing and like sometimes she's
wearing like a massive Chanel bag but
sometimes like I don't know it looks a
little costume shut day let me tell you
back to this arena I wrote something
down that like really made me laugh in I
think it was maybe the last two episodes
ago they're sitting at the bar and Teddy
orders and Aperol spritz and Lisa
Rinna's like Oh what we know I try that
too
for literally the rest of the time their
member linds you notice that Lisa Rinna
only orders Aperol spritz she's drinking
the orange drink the whole time I must
have missed it because my I've had this
buffering okay it's just funny like I
love like watching little things okay
someone here says I don't think they're
mad at Erica for being upset about being
called a liar I think they're upset with
dead delivery that Erica said it [ __ ]
that it was one sentence no but it's
like everyone so mean to each other no
one really is like taking responsibility
for any of their actions Lisa Vanderpump
is the devil no one says anything Erica
says one thing a little harshly and now
we're all sensitive please please okay
know what I really did not like but when
Erica brought it up again my famous turn
yeah I agree then it was smoothed over
and even Teddy is shady in her comments
first of all Teddy like a so brave in
her comments and then it comes time for
the actual setting and she's like yeah
yes she's crying I can't she's one of
those
she's like so Erica didn't offer me an
olive branch but a Mimi was like Charlie
Brown's Christmas tree I don't a she
offered you a [ __ ] olive branch
she's so annoying okay this is the next
thing that Teddy that really pissed me
off like I hate when people do this like
when they all were going on the boat and
then Joey came down in her outfit Erica
came down in her outfit and Lisa Rinna
came down out of it she was like is this
a costume party that she was making fun
of people's a style choices which like I
hate when people do that cuz I even if I
don't agree with someone style choices
like to wear something different it's
like a form of bravery I think like you
know that people can make fun of you and
like I think that like that girl who's
making fun of other people's outfit
choices is obviously so insecure and
like Jimmy looked so cute Erica looked
interesting like I would never wear it
but it was it she was up relating looks
be committed to the asset lisa rinna
looked amazing like i don't know and
like she was just like judging them
obviously in her in the moment side
interview is not in person
so just like making fun of their efforts
I hate girls who do that like I also
hate girls who are like annoying in what
they wear but like it takes especially
when you're on TV it takes a certain
courage to like wear something different
and cool and interesting and even if it
doesn't mind taking a chance tile wise
is like a brave thing to do and like
just like making fun of them is such a
good obvious insecurity like and she
said before that she's not into clothes
or whatever and she's like she looked
fine she was wearing like leggings like
whatever I just didn't like the Harker
drive I did oh yeah I did an obvious
choice I didn't like that you made fun
of them it really pissed me off
I completely agree and it's more than
that it's like these women clearly spend
hours and like have flown their glam
teams over and it's not like they just
like oh okay you know I'll do this today
so yeah they spent so long like getting
driving a PDF of their outfits for us
like for the viewer it's like to make
this show a little more interesting and
dynamic and to put on a show for us and
like respect not respect German culture
but you know try and embrace it I
totally agree and I saw I totally agree
with you that that was so rude and it
says more about her than it does about
that I totally and Lisa Rinna's body I
[ __ ] love ceramics we have to get her
on the show she is epic she have been so
crazy a few seasons ago when she was
being that's like Rebecca my friend
Becky we was like I love Lisa Rinna and
like they remind me so much of each
other just their energy yeah like I
don't when she gets to I feel like Lisa
Rinna is my friend
yeah when Lisa Rinna when they all get
to that be German beer hall two episodes
ago and before they sit down listen Tina
starts dancing like that's what we would
do and it's like all of them weren't
gonna dance until like Rinna starts
dancing so Erika starts dancing and then
it's been Kyle because she's found an
injury and then so everyone gets up but
it's always the first nut remember that
TED talks yes it's so hard to be the
first nut and it's hard to be the second
nut but then all the other nuts are just
followers so we're the first ten seconds
left okay who's the first it doesn't
it's relevant I'm just saying with like
we're the first you my third and final
thought about Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills is Lisa Vanderpump thank God went
home early and when she gets back to LA
she and it showed so much of what yes
the problem is with the show when she
gets back to LA she has two scenes
back-to-back in the first scene she
works in Mercer
the first thing she goes she's talking
to her colleague get better my drugs I
really hate getting a woods second scene
she's talking to Kyle a silence comes
she goes so I got this award
she's like waiting for crowd to be like
oh yeah tell me about the award
recognized yeah no it's like but I
thought you hated awards no and it's
like it was just them going going from
Berlin to Vanderpump dogs like was so
indicative of what's wrong with the show
yeah I told her seems I'm her own are
unbelievably boring no matter how many
cute dogs you throw in the mix and to
like if she had been in that dinner when
Erica and Teddy started having she's got
a mob spoken on behalf of Teddy
escalated the situation instead
everyone's fine and a Charlie Brant
Brown Christmas branch was offered Lisa
would have gotten involved and then Kyle
would have gotten involved and then Joey
would have gotten involved and then it
would have been about their like weird
trio thing I can't stand Lisa Vanderpump
like I really hope she doesn't come back
I feel like it's coming but we've been
saying this for so long
yeah but she she doesn't even want to be
there and then I watch hands I had last
night they addressed Lisa Rinna's radio
and II interview and Lisa Vanderpump it
totally took it out of context she said
that Lisa Rinna said on radio Andy that
the old girls basically Kyle and Lisa
should be kicked out and they should
bring in some new blood which is in fact
not what she said Lisa Rinna said all I
said was that we need new blood which
they do desperately yeah who would you
who would you give the boot to Lisa
Vanderpump okay teddy
okay but Teddy's technically new blood
yeah I know but she sucks yeah but I
love herself I know I can't believe
people love her oh you know what I've
been wanting to do this I want to do a
poll I'm gonna run a poll on my Twitter
right now at girl with no job if you're
watching I want you to bow they grab
your phone or computer whatever you're
on okay okay pull do we love our hey
teddy like let's just let's finish it
once and for all
do we love or hate teddy question mark
hashtag all right you know one sheet
said there's nothing to hate really I
hate it
whose side are you on Erica or Teddy
Erica
no but ask people okay I don't hate you
are you on Team Erica or team Jane oh no
or team what's her name Teddy Teddy
poles he does look like Kendra
teddy Erica um she does it's a good call
are you on Team America or team Teddy I
tweeted it girl with no job Twitter
please vote I'm just curious like I
would I would really need to rethink
like my own set of values and principles
if like everyone is disagreeing with me
do you know any me I'm courting to watch
what happens live and some of our
comments everyone is disagreeing with
you but it's also because people we've
also defended to read this season and
people are so really not like yeah but I
can understand why people don't like her
I don't see how anyone could not like
Erica is it weird and I'm like excited
about Beverly no it's really cute it's
really like when we get the preview of
the curtain dropping like it looks good
and I've seen some of it on her
Instagram it was really good this
everywhere and is so cute yeah brilliant
I'm glad they change the name yeah just
it's such a different vibe like Beverly
Beach reminds me of what was that
clothing line back in the day like the
Beverly Hills it was like so like Paris
Hilton like would wear it they the
Beverly Hills something you guys know
what I'm talking about it's like those
t-shirts that said Beverly Hills I don't
remember but it's like it's very cute
ethereally it's like very boutique II
has been married Beverly Hills you know
it's usually embrace your newfound fame
yeah and I usually hate when like the
housewives like turn their platform into
like a business they're trying to run
like when [ __ ] they make like hair
product or whatever it's so annoying
yeah we're like wine yeah it's so Ramona
Pinot Grigio is so no but she was the
first yeah but then it became a trend
like Brandi made away its annoy I think
Teresa had but I actually really am
enjoying watching to read make it yeah
cuz she's obviously good at it and like
when they like Ramona had never been a
wine connoisseur before like to read
actually has a long-standing career and
being a businesswoman when it comes to
bikinis but Ramona like did really put
peanut I didn't know what Pinot Grigio
was before Ramona but also because I was
under yeah so you probably would have
known about it even without her I don't
know but then I would then I wouldn't
order a Pinot Grigio and I felt like
people knew I was underage so they must
have just been ordering from house to
house gave Pinot Grigio a bad name
that's true but now I think it's good
again I like I sell order a Pinot grig
so next week is a season finale of
Beverly Hills real it was fast
yeah oh my god I didn't even watch it I
knew I did watch a PV sooner actually
mean it said it in the season finale of
frozen reunions I always get my hopes up
except
Vanakkam rules is always juicy but how
those your unions always get my hopes up
and then they fall flat like nothing
Armenians are always juicy because so
much happens in the downtime like on
Twitter on social media in the media and
yeah joggers yeah but with Beverly Hills
they're not so tight like I don't know
they're really losing it I know and I
feel like they're sensing that that's
why Rinna was like new blood yeah I
[ __ ] love Lisa Rinna them casting
he's gotta get her on the show was it
really someone who commented like we
should also get her daughters totally I
loved Delilah yeah I'm we dia okay we're
gonna get Lisa right now I'm Adam we met
her at Coachella we did meet her she
came up to us she recognized us yes she
was like oh my god was on job and I was
like oh my god July without have one
everyone forgets the headline you guys
everyone forgets that Harry Hamlin will
never have to work another day in his
life totally and he makes apparently the
most mazing pies I love Harry Hamlin
cook for me I think totally I mean I
would let really anyone cook for me it's
also crazy that Lisa Oberman this is my
lovely Superman if she has rats in her
house and she puts that [ __ ] on TV oh my
god they there's literally nothing more
did you say oh that Lisa Vanderpump has
rocked in her house she is so much yeah
but she hasn't as pets
she's Gustav she can distinguish between
like what's your pet and like what's
like vermin the outside of her house is
absolutely gorgeous the inside of our
house like it's a facade please help me
because remember when she'll didn't even
the bigger house yeah what was that
house called Chuckie I don't know it
wasn't good was Anka okay no no I will
tell you Lisa Vanderpump first house
named bigger she names all of her houses
love Villa Rosa and I just always want
to call the other house Villa Blanca
Lisa Vanderpump old house name anyone
know I'm looking it up give me two
seconds
look we're former mansion hold on French
chateau hold on
Hollywood Reporter maybe it was like
Rubirosa that's the pizza place I've
never been there okay hold on it's not
centered it keeps me up on at night do
any of our listeners know I don't no
one's commenting but maybe my phone is
just free what a sort of old house I
don't know all right let me go back to
my Twitter poll Oh how's it doing 67%
300 votes so far that's pretty good yeah
I'm just worried that the tides will
turn people are responding in Jeff's I
love me people we talked about it I'll
see you more minutes you want to talk
about Jersey Shore before this Thursday
yes there's so much to talk about
I'm it's so good I love Jersey Shore me
too there is an O like in a cloud of
depression over it not depression but
more like inauthenticity
because they like they came up so
authentically like their show was good
because they were animals and they
weren't afraid to do stuff and this was
before reality TV was like really
developed into like this genre it's
become and like how it's so scripted
like there was not one producer involved
in the old seasons of Jersey Shore like
they did it all themselves like they
said what they wanted they did what they
wanted they drank what they wanted they
ate with it like they were just doing it
themselves now they're all just more
reserved because they all have like a
lot to lose like DJ Pauly D is like a
real career like that he can't anyways
nothing to lose is Ronnie the Dana and
or actually situation has a lot to lose
yeah freedom the dynamics of how
everyone's post show success has leveled
out is it so crazy it makes me like so
sad I mean II just if there's something
like sad about yes show like seeing like
has been reality stars like what they're
up to now some of them have done such
great things like Pauly Pauly New Jersey
and jenni but then like say you just did
and even like Vinny is like an Internet
star right now like I seen him on the
show was actually weird to me because I
just know him from like Twitter and yeah
saying funny [ __ ] about the bachelor in
his podcast and like he has he's carved
out a life for him something he lives on
Staten Island where he's from which is a
very like important band Joe sort of
thing I do which I love but then it's
like Ronnie
he lives in Nevada he doesn't live I'm
like in Vegas like really and then there
is the situation well I mean literally
was giving me AJ Northey but he's still
so funny and by the way I watch I'm in
the middle I'm on season four of the old
season and yes he was totally the
villain but he made that show yeah all
those words like like cabs are here
t-shirt I'm like I'm watching that with
Vinny and Pauly it was not able
situation and it gets misconstrued he is
literally like he fostered that culture
like beating up the
like I'm reaching and I'm like shocked
by like everyone hates him but he made
the show really what it is like he was
the catalyst he started a lot of the
drama like he was in the middle of it he
all like the colloquia lives we use from
Jersey
it's like he's Mike because he was the
ringleader of the boys for the first few
seasons then he spiraled out of control
and Vinny and Pauly really came up it's
like the two like cuz they're obviously
like you know like GTL Baba bah but then
they also are quirky and funny and weird
and America embraced that side of them
but I agree but situation was giving me
a pip because like I haven't done so
said I didn't done my taxes yet Oh God
and I was like I couldn't watch the show
it was like sweating I was getting to do
my taxes since I watched it I did my
taxes so maybe I'll enjoy this week a
little bit more but it really is so sad
and we defended him on the show because
it's hard when they're coming up and
you're making a lot of money really
quickly and you would never made a lot
of money before yeah you don't know what
you keep that you have to pay your taxes
what tax bracket you're in like all this
stuff no one ever tells you and when I'm
sure when MTV is giving them those
checks they're not like make sure you
pay your taxes they don't support with a
financial advisor right so I really do
feel for him and I it's just crazy that
his freedom is on the line and that girl
with him right now is so cute at high
school sweetheart is an angel from
heaven I can't believe he's sober though
and that like he's going to clubs and
stuff and like it must be really hard
really really hard but okay I wait talk
quickly about my Robin Sam because I am
and this is I'm about to get serious and
like say something like not nice but I'm
rewatching and like from what we know as
kids as like they were just like The
Annoying couple that I was always
fighting but like now was a good an
adult woman watching it like it's a
totally abusive relationship Ron is like
so mentally like manipulative and like
I'm not surprised at all that Ronnie
Jenna I mean that's a need to not go
back she had her part in being the most
annoying [ __ ] human being in the
relationship and being a drama queen but
like I'm watching the show and like he
is insane and like now even watching him
in the new season he has not changed
whatsoever like even just the way he
speaks to Deena it's like so
condescending and like the way he speaks
he is a real [ __ ] problem and I
really don't like him and like watching
and though I can't watch old seasons
it's so painful and I never thought
anything of it as a kid because like to
me they were just like
boyfriend/girlfriend like stupid but
they're 23
in the show and I'm 23 and like watching
them like what he says and what he does
is not okay he's so manipulative he
controls her mind and I'm not surprised
whatsoever that she didn't go back and
the fact that he's still making fun of
her it's like really pissing me off I
totally agree thank you for saying that
look I mean that's brings like something
I felt so scripted that they would never
have done in the last season's is the
doll it's so stupid so stupid like we
don't need stuff like that like just put
a GoPro on Snooki's far ahead and let's
[ __ ] go not even that what we need
like is this is exactly what we need
Vinny breaking down the door when the
beat drops like that's quintessential
unscripted funny Jersey Shore like we
need more of that and like something is
going on with Johnny
like why is Lou he's all afraid of him I
don't think she's afraid of him I think
I feel like I've always felt that they
had a good relationship I mean I don't
know anything about it I watch the shows
social media no I don't use go 90 no it
was on MTV for a while I did watch a
fire like it was kid onus yeah you know
it's good I like I like I'm enjoying the
damn it's obviously a little rusty was a
lamp sidewalk nobody it seems like
obviously their lives have changed a lot
and now it's like they're just blacking
out and hoping something interesting
happens yes like Snooki losing her ring
which is just Hitsville that's it's
totally pistol but where did it go I
don't know and they have they film the
whole thing they can watch it fly off
totally it's so annoying like break
Vinny needs to get in the club and break
down the fourth wall holy that is too
true just zoom in it slowing off at some
point yeah let's go good she's still
wearing it I'm like no it's so annoying
buzzer I am doll is Mitch oh god but the
neighbors definitely think there's a
dead body in the pool for sure when they
got to the house I was wondering where
they were all freaking out so much about
like having a pool then it occurred to
me at their jersey house they never had
a pool yeah but like when now you think
of every reality show like they always
have a pool like The Bachelor has a pool
they had a hot tub yeah but like a pool
is different and like a changes like
your whole vibe and it was likewise
different for young but the poor fools
at the shore it's on the MTV DJ pool
it's like you're on the ocean when we do
that reality show like are you the one
they obviously have a pool out of The
Bachelor has a pool Flowerbomb ashore
has a tiny pool but like I was at a
party
yeah and it's a green yeah it's gross oh
I remember sure it's still gonna
chemically but I think I may know it's
about Jersey Shore cuz I just wanted to
make sure I talked about everything but
it was mostly about situation and his
taxes ya know it's really sad and how
he's like out of shape and he looks so
different like his face yeah we Paulie
has a kid he does you missed that
he's a daughter he was talking about it
I told him is that yeah I was like half
watching on my phone oh my god it was
like subliminal because when Ronnie's
telling him about the baby and then
Ronnie goes you know what it's like man
he was like yeah and then a couple times
throughout the episode he talks about
his daughter oh my god I missed that but
he's not like in a relationship right he
is a life is crazy yeah I didn't realize
how successful he was as a DJ I read a
story about him I think a complex did a
profile on him like always doing the
most important profiles important
profiles and it was about how like he
turned being just like a like when he
was DJing and the first piece is like it
was [ __ ] sad yes I agree the laptop
and he turned it into like a huge huge
career for himself and it's like he's
obviously not the smartest cast member
hmm but he's the most successful one and
I just want to know like who was amazing
him yeah because it's [ __ ] brilliant
I didn't know that he was so successful
so much money until they showed his
house I was like freaking out his
Bentley's yeah I knew he was so
successful because of that profile and
also like are they gonna talk about
Aubrey O'Day are they going to talk
about Donald Trump jr. oh my god it's
just I love how full circle take an
episode of Seinfeld it's all come back
it's like this it's so so crazy and also
so many of them did famously single or
just maybe Ronnie and yeah because
they're the only single ones and I
didn't know Ben he had a girlfriend yes
she seems really cute yeah I don't feel
like it's gonna last I don't know I it
can't only be probably he's single on
this like where's the drama then you
know that's a problem it's like what we
loved like the smoosh room like grenades
like that can't really happen that's the
problem
yeah oh my god I want to see the pole
butts and let's round out the show with
the pole ready okay oh yeah I think it's
time to go and we also haven't spoken
about we're honing yet but it's on
tonight I believe yes so we'll talk
about it then okay um Teddy vs. Erica we
have 300 votes 63%
okay Erica I love our viewers I'm
actually like it's just gonna turn soon
but thank you guys so much for tuning in
as always make sure you're following in
the morning toast show on Instagram or
on Facebook we're in the podcast app or
on youtube subscribe premium content
always being delivered we're back
tomorrow 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
recapping grill houses in New York and
anything else that's not tomorrow what
else I think yeah whatever pick it up
okay yes any time knows on Monday it was
I missed it whatever whatever was just
getting away from us bye guys have a
good day